Adidas has ended its lucrative
partnership with rapper Kanye West after
he made a series of anti-semitic remarks
the sportswear maker said it does not
tolerate anti-Semitism or any other sort
of hate speech West Drew widespread
criticism following several outbursts on
his Twitter and Instagram accounts in
recent months he also accused Adidas of
stealing his designs the abrupt end to
the partnership is expected to as much
as half the company's profit this year
Adidas's move comes a few days after
Kanye West boasted on a podcast I can
say anti-semitic things and Adidas can't
drop me well he was wrong
and joining us now is friend of the show
Alison Stewart Allen she's back to break
the story down for us she's CEO of
international marketing partners and an
advisor to Major luxury and Retail
Brands
um so Alison how significant is this
announcement for Adidas
well it's very significant because they
were pinning their hopes on Kanye West
being someone that generates positive
brand awareness and also ultimately
sales and this is the only reason really
any brand uh takes on a celebrity
endorser or influencer and unfortunately
this has very badly backfired for Adidas
uh I don't think they ever expected
they'd be in this situation uh and now
they're unfortunately having to
remediately put a clean up operation uh
in place uh to try to you know minimize
the damage that's been inflicted on the
brand by being associated with him and
some of his uh very unpopular and not
mainstream points of view so I think
this company unfortunately is going to
rethink all together whether it
continues with celebrity endorsements uh
and if it does then and it needs to be
much more careful interesting that it's
not just an image problem that Adidas
has now it will significantly affect
their bottom line because just this line
of Yeezy uh shoes made them a
significant chunk of their profit so how
do or even how should big clothing
brands like Adidas balance the risks and
rewards of close association with big
name celebrities
yes well unfortunately Adidas aren't
alone uh you know there are a number of
other Global brands that have had
celebrity tie-ups in the past and they
have been let down by the behavior of
you know the celebrity who is a human
and let's be honest you know if you're
going to engage a human uh then that
comes with all sorts of risks because
humans are unpredictable humans may not
have the values that map on to your
brand they may do crazy things I mean
there's a litany in the marketing
literature of companies who have used
celebrities and it's all gone very very
wrong so I think now uh the question for
Adidas is what do we do differently uh
how do we manage this easy uh shoe and
the range given they've cut ties with
him my my expectation is they're going
to destroy the stock uh the inventory uh
and they're going to move on as quickly
as possible uh and do what they're doing
now which is making clear that they do
not endorse any of the points of view uh
that he's been putting forward uh around
White lives matter around the
anti-semitic
um uh public social media posts and
public posts or Public Communication uh
so the best they can do is distance
themselves as quickly as possible
because certainly he has proven a
liability
okay so Adidas shares as we've seen this
year are down 60 and this is of course
making things worse so if we may solicit
some free advice from you
um you know if you said a bit about what
they should do next but should they
consider other brand endorsements I mean
companies like this are doing it all the
time or do you think they should stay
away from that for a little while
I think they should continue
person or people much more carefully uh
have a take longer to understand the
risks involved with that particular
person and once they have chosen that
particular person continue to do that
due diligence and make sure that they uh
can get out of that relationship uh
should That Celebrity put the brand at
risk and clearly in this case and in
many other cases celebrities and uh
influencers do put those brands at risk
so you have to be super careful when you
back uh and engage a person to do these
sorts of endorsements yeah it seems
there can be big gains but also it's a
serious risk as well if things do go
wrong Alison Stuart Allen from
International marketing Partners as
always it's a pleasure to have you on
thank you very much
and for more of this now let's cross
over to entertainment journalists Ron's
a song beta he is in Washington DC it's
good to have you with us um give us a
background on this cooperation I mean
what meaning did Kanye West have for the
Adidas brand and Adidas for Kanye West
well for Adidas it's arguably their most
important partnership it's made the
company about two billion a year which
is just under 10 of the total revenue
there is no other partnership that
compares and for Kanye it's made of a
billionaire you know it's it's um it's
he's gone from I mean he's no longer
billionaire as of a few hours ago
according to Forbes but as of March of
last year he was worth 6.6 billion
dollars and that is largely because of
the success of Yeezy he's not worth only
400 million which is I mean more than
I've ever had but yes I think that's
more than any of us have to be honest
with you you know there have been strong
reactions here in Germany uh the
chairman of the council the central
Council of Jews in Germany I'm Joseph
Schuster said that it would have been
unbearable if a German company had
continued its cooperation with someone
who has been accused of anti-Semitism
what has the reaction been there in the
United States
yeah it's been just as negative on uh
you know uh his lawyer Camille Camille
Vasquez who was uh claims of Fame was
worked with Johnny Depp actually ended
her working relationship with him his
agency CAA which is the largest agency
in Hollywood has cut ties with Kanye a
completed documentary which was uh you
know plan for release in the next year
has been shelved because of this and
Vogue magazine and its editor-in-chief
Anna Wintour announced that they will no
longer work at Kanye so it's been
overwhelmingly negative and there
unfortunately there's a minority of
people who do support Kanye so uh
earlier this week in Los Angeles a group
of neo-nazis went to the highway to say
that Kanye was right so while the
reaction has been over only negative
unfortunately there are people who are
seeing this as an opportunity to spray
hate and Kanye West or yay as he calls
himself
um today has made anti-semitic comments
and interviews and social media for
weeks now where would you say that his
career is had
so unfortunately he's made this type of
hate speech part of his brand uh long
before the anti-Semitism those lots of
anti-black comments uh even nine years
ago he wore a jacket with a Confederate
flag stitching so this is really not new
and this is now a part of his brand and
I think he'll be banished to the fringes
of of Hollywood and of Public Square he
will always have a following but it will
be uh cult following and he will
continue to be a useful idiot for right
wing Outlets
journalist ranze esangbedo joining us
tonight from Washington D.C we
appreciate your reporting thank you